Iranians have taken to the streets in  protests triggered by the death of Masa  amini the 22 year old Kurdish woman died  on the 16th of September at the hands of  morality police in Tehran they claimed  she'd been wearing her hijab incorrectly  dozens of people have been killed in the  protests which have sparked expressions  of support around the world  MEPS condemned the Authority's use of  force and called on Iran to respect  fundamental rights we as European  Parliament stand in solidarity with  the brave women and men in their fight  for women's human and minority rights  for the free flow of information and  access to Internet and for a free  secular and Democratic Republic Europa  estas protestas  you has demanded a full investigation  into Masa amini's death and is  considering further restricted measures  against Iran